>> Tucker: ALEC SCAR LOTTO
EXPERIENCE STONE AND SADLER
HALTED TERROR ATTACK ON A
FRENCH TRAIN IN 2015 LIKELY
SAVING MANY LIVES.
THAT GOT THE WORLD’S
ATTENTION AND ALSO
HOLLYWOOD’S RATHER THAN HAVE
ACTORS PLAY THE THREE
FRIENDS, DIRECTOR CLINTON
EASTWOOD HAD THEM PLAY
THEMSELVES IN THE UPCOMING
FILM 15:17 TO PARIS.
ALEC, SPENCER AND ANTHONY
JOIN US TONIGHT.
GREAT TO SEE YOU GUYS.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING US.
>> Tucker: NOT ONLY DID YOU
DO THIS AND ONE THE GREAT
GOOD DEEDS EVER BUT YOU GOT
WHOLE NEW CAREERS OUT OF IT
WHAT WAS IT LIKE -- HAD ANY
OF YOU ACTED BEFORE.
>> NEVER, NEVER.
NOT EVEN A SCHOOL PLAY.
>> Tucker: WELL THEN TO GO
FROM LIKE ZERO TO HOLLYWOOD
FILM DIRECTED BY CLINTON
EASTWOOD IS A LOT.
HOW DID YOU DO IT.
>> WE HONESTLY DID IT HOW WE
DID THE FIRST TIME REALLY.
THAT’S THE ONLY ADVICE HE
GAVE US TO BE OURSELVES AND
DO IT HOW WE DID IT?
>> ONLY CLINT EASTWOOD COULD
PULL SOMETHING LIKE THIS
OFF.
HE GAVE US THE CONFIDENCE TO
ATTEMPT IT WE HAD TO TRY IT.
>> WE TRUSTED HIM SO MUCH.
WE KNEW GOING INTO IT HE
WOULD DO THE STORY JUSTICE
AND JUST HAVING HIM LIKE
ANTHONY SAID HAVING THE
CONFIDENCE IN US WAS ALL WE
NEEDED.
>> Tucker: WAS IT HARD?
>> IT WAS FUN.
I MEAN IT WAS HARD AT FIRST
GETTING USED TO IT.
BUT I THINK WE KIND OFLY
THEMED WITH IT PRETTY
QUICKLY AND ACTUALLY
FINISHED AHEAD OF SCHEDULE,
I THINK.
>> HE TAKES THE WEIGHT OF
SHOOTING A BIG MOTION
PICTURE OFF OF YOU.
HE KEEPS IT REAL LIGHT.
YOU WHERE YOUR TWO FRIENDS.
DO WHAT YOU DID AND I WILL
CAPTURE THE REST.
WHEN CLINT EASTWOOD SAYS
THAT YOU HAVE GOT TO TRUST
HIM ON THAT.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
SO WHAT WAS IT LIKE FILMING
THE PIVOTAL SCENE IN THE
MOVIE AND IN YOUR LIVES ON
THE TRAIN?
>> IT WAS HONESTLY JUST A
LOT OF FUN.
I MEAN, A LOT OF PEOPLE
THINK IT WOULD BE TRAM
ADVERTISING BUT LUCKILY WE
DON’T HAVE PTSD.
NOBODY DIED THAT DAY ON THE
TRAIN.
I MEAN, WE JUST GOT TO HANG
OUT FOR A WEEK ON THE TRAIN
WITH TWO BEST FRIENDS AND
CLINT EASTWOOD.
>> YOU GET TO DO IT TWICE
THAT’S PRETTY COOL.
MORE THAN JUST A HEADLINE.
EVERYBODY GETS TO SEE
ACTUALLY WHAT HAPPENED.
HOW MESSY AND CRAZY IT WAS.
AND HOPEFULLY IT INSPIRES
PEOPLE TO MAYBE DO SOMETHING
IN THOSE SITUATIONS.
>> Tucker: THAT’S IT RIGHT
THERE.
I’M NOT JUDGING ANYONE.
I HAVEN’T BEEN IN THAT KIND
OF SITUATION.
YOU SEE A LOT OF THESE
THINGS UNFOLD AND NOBODY
DOES THAT WHY DO YOU THINK
THAT IS?
>> PEOPLE ARE SCARED.
WHICH WE WERE SCARED AS
WELL, TOO.
I THINK THE UNIQUE THING
ABOUT OUR SITUATION IS WE
WERE JUST ON A TRAIN AND WE
HAD NOWHERE TO GO.
SO I KNOW ALL THESE
SITUATIONS ARE DIFFERENT.
YOU KNOW, ALL THESE
DIFFERENT ATTACKS AND STUFF
LIKE THAT.
BUT HOPEFULLY THIS CHANGES
THE NARRATIVE A LITTLE BIT
AND INSPIRES PEOPLE OUT
THERE, YOU KNOW, THE COMMON
MAN CAN DO SOMETHING IF THEY
FIND THEMSELVES IN THE SAME
SITUATION.
>> Tucker: YEAH, IF THEY ARE
BRAVE, WHICH YOU GUYS ARE.
AND THAT’S ALWAYS THE KEY.
HAD ANY OF YOU THOUGHT A
SCENARIO OF LIKE THAT
THROUGH IF I’M EVER IN A
SITUATION LIKE THAT THIS IS
WHAT I’M GOING THROUGH.
>> WE KIND OF PLAYED WAR
GROWING UP TOGETHER.
WE ALWAYS ASKED EACH OTHER
LIKE IF A GUY COMES IN THIS
ROOM WHAT ARE YOU GOING TO
DO?
ANSWERS WERE ALWAYS THE
SAME.
>> THAT WAS THE BIGGEST
CONTRIBUTING FACTOR IS OUR
FRIENDSHIP GOING BACK SO FAR
AND WE ALL KNEW WE WOULD BE
ON THE SAME PAGE IF
HAPPENED.